foreign
my name's James and I'm an English
teacher from the UK over the last week
or so I've torn down all of my classroom
posters displays wall arts and recycle
them and put them into the bin and my
all of my students which who are
teenagers have been walking into my room
saying it looks so boring it's really
depressing now just the walls are gray
and there's no Sparkle there's no
personality in here and I've tried to
explain the idea of minimalism and
visual clutter and distractions but they
just think it's quite boring and I was
wondering if you had any tips or advice
on what I can say to them
well of course
our judgment is a mirror of our own
preferences
and so yeah maybe it is boring to them
and you're always going to be boring to
somebody
and that's okay I don't mind if you're
bored by me I'm not going to drag you
into my boredom I'm not going to ask you
to also be bored with me
and yet if I did everything that I want
to do in order to appease someone else
to pacify their boredom to make sure
they aren't bored Brian it seems to me
that as an extrovert I know this is
something with you you are an
entertainer of people even when you're
not on a stage somewhere you become the
life of the party and part of that is
you aren't boring and I know that I
generally am if I'm at a party I'm
really boring I'm the guy over in the
corner sort of observing what's going on
and I'm not I'm going out of my way to
avoid talking with people you're you're
the opposite of that because but it's
not because oh I'm afraid of being
boring it's because you're compelled
to
interact
sure yeah first off I don't think you're
boring a parties Josh
um you're boring all the time not just
parties
just kidding man no I've never thought
about that uh I thought that about you
to party um for me uh yeah I mean just I
just I like
um I like laughing and I like making
other people laugh
um and that's just kind of ingrained in
me but
with James here
um man if someone if someone came to me
and said oh you know this room in your
house looks empty and if I said to them
well it's because I'm a minimalist that
doesn't
really open up a conversation
so so James you know I'm not telling you
what you should or shouldn't say to
people but if someone comes to you and
says oh this is really
um boring then what you can do is
explain to them why for you it's not
boring like oh like wow like I see what
you're saying like there's I took down
some of the stuff but
um look at all this like open space like
it's a blank canvas for us to do
whatever we want but to to just respond
with like well I'm a minimalist and
minimalism is about having fewer things
um yes like people aren't going to be as
compelled to learn more about you know
why you took all that stuff down but you
know ultimately James you don't have to
explain yourself to anybody
that's right and you can show them that
and I think this is what you're doing
here you're showing some of them at
least that minimalism exposes The beauty
within the bones yeah right so stripping
away that which is Superfluous if you
had Superfluous posters and it's
Superfluous to you because it's highly
individual here but if it was
Superfluous to you and you're letting
those go someone else not everyone else
be clear not everyone's going to find
Value in that but someone else is going
to say oh wow this is calmer it's like
when I first started simplifying Ryan
came to me he said why the hell are you
so happy
there are other people were like Oh no
you're getting rid of your stuff you
must be suicidal I want all my stuff I
need more stuff I need to cling to
myself I never have enough
okay
that's fine I understand is always what
I say now
in fact when my daughter was oh this is
really boring
I understand
because I don't need to explain myself I
don't need to prove myself no no no I'm
not boring I swear to you you're boring
I understand yeah yeah
I think about Stephen pressfield in the
war of art he says the more important
some task is to your Soul's Calling the
more likely you will experience
resistance from the world when you move
in the direction of that calling
sometimes we make these changes because
it might create more space for health or
wealth or Wellness in our lives and then
the people around us say well I don't
like that change that makes you less
funny to me less interesting to me less
convenient for me and we have to make a
decision in those moments can we still
love ourselves even when other people
hate us for the changes that we make and
sometimes if we can say yes to that then
we find that the people that initially
hate us might come around and warm up
and say I'm glad you stuck to it I'm
glad you stayed true to yourself or
sometimes those people may fade away and
that too can be a good thing because
it's not really a loss if the people
that are falling away from you are
people that were holding you back from
being true to yourself
the next thing I'd say is there's a
difference between explaining yourself
and demanding that other people accept
your explanation sometimes when we love
people and we want them to know where
we're coming from we say hey look just
so you know that this isn't personal or
arbitrary here is the reason why I'm
doing this and they may listen to that
and say yeah well I still don't like it
there's room in those moments to say I
respect your opinion and I also hope
that you can respect my decision
last thing
if the opinions of your students happen
to be important to you and you want them
to feel good about the way the room
looks there is possibility for
compromise in the making of a creative
project out of it you can say to the
students hey look I'm not anti-art I'm
not anti-embellishment I just don't want
my classroom filled with clutter so how
about this we can put up two pictures
only two but as a class we're going to
decide what two pictures represent the
spirit and energy of this group and then
you can get them involved and they can
have a say on what the class looks like
within the boundaries that you establish
for what's aesthetically pleasing to you
that could create a win-win scenario
just the possibility did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free